they kept saying tools they kept saying
tools we've got one doctor what do you
want us to do we've got no beds
available what do you want us to do
we've got no space for him what do you
want us to do
complain to the big people don't
complain to us this is the grief that
comes with bearing a child
ten days ago Yusuf became ill his GP
described antibiotics for a sore throat
but Yusuf became much sicker it was seen
and sent home by doctors at Rotherham
General Hospital
just two weeks before he died two weeks
before he died
such a lovely kid
[Music]
but when his condition deteriorated
further his family begged for Yusuf to
be admitted to hospital
he's lost a beautiful child and it's not
his fault We begged and begged and
begged for help
we couldn't get it we just did not get
the help we wanted all we needed or we
should have got
the family managed to have use of scene
by specialists at Sheffield children's
hospital but it was too late his
infection had spread to his lungs and on
Monday he died from pneumonia
if Yusuf was passed away if he can save
one child we're happy
we do not want anybody to go through
this and we'll just asking them to
please listen to people
Rotherham General Hospital's chief
executive has offered his condolences to
yusuf's family and told Sky News we have
commenced a thorough investigation into
yusuf's care which will include liaison
with Sheffield children's NHS Foundation
Trust
one of the country's leading pediatric
consultants told me that while the
crisis in adult Health Care was
recognized it was probably the same if
not worse for children he said today
there were no intensive care beds for
children available anywhere south of
stoke and a sick child had to be
transferred from Wales to his Hospital
in London
NHS England has told Sky News it has
written to trusts warning of a
potentially record rise in demand for
treatment of respiratory viruses it
comes after we reported a national
shortage of pediatric ICU beds across
the country
that is going to be worrying news for
parents across the country the important
thing is that the fear that a story like
this brings is not a deterrent to
parents to seeking the medical attention
when their child is sick
Joseph's family want and deserve answers
nothing will bring their little boy back
but it could spare another family from
going through the same anguish artist
Joshi Sky News in Rotherham